Decision Trees are powerful
modelling technique.
But like all techniques
the algorithm can have its issues.
Decision Trees are prone to
an error called overfitting
where the model fits the sample
data a little too well and
as a result does not predict future
results as well so it should.
A technique that helps eliminate
this issue is a Random Forest Model.
Let's go over a little background
of what a forest model actually is,
to build out a forest model, let us
start by building a decision tree.
If you recall, the decision tree
is constructed by looking for
groups to split, or Data.
Splits are chosen at places to produce
the largest difference and for this
example, the largest difference in the
percent of the mode of transportation.
We will continue down this path
creating different splits of the data
until adding more splits
no longer adds value
in predicting the correct
mode of transportation.
Now what if we made the same tree
with slightly different data,
would it be exactly the same?
No, changes in the data could cause the
tree to split at different points, or
in a different order.
A forest model creates
hundreds of trees.
This is call an assemble of decision
trees, where each tree is created by
different randomly generated
chunks of the original data.
Then it looks at the results as
a whole to make a prediction.
So, how does this fix the overfitting
problem we mentioned before?
Well each individual tree created
still has the overfitting issues, but
when you look at the result as a whole.
The overfitting gets averaged
out by all the other trees.
The first decision tree will be created
with a subset of the original data.
We'll also use a different combination
of predictor variables to assist with
the splits along the trees.
The second decision tree will
then do the exact same thing
with a different subset of data
with different predictor variables
being used to help with
the splits as well.
This will continue to occur until the
number of decision trees specified has
been created.
By default this value
is 500 decision trees.
Now each employee will
traverse through each tree
until they reaches a terminal node.
At each of the terminal nodes,
the decision tree has a vote.
Car, public transit or bike.
The terminal node that
is seem most often
is then classified as the group
that employee falls within.